jeremy thank you so much for coming down
from wales
you have done super super well um you're
making
you're financially free now yeah how
does it feel
really good excellent yeah excellent
what what what um
what how did it all start what happened
give me the background
so taking it right back december 2018
um in my local area the bridge toll
was was scrapped therefore my house
price went up
so that allowed me to pour some equity
out and in and around january
i found your youtube channel um
so i followed you consistently for for a
few
weeks and months and then around
roundabout
was it generally me i attended the the
launch pad
so so sorry the crash court yeah 2018.
this is 2018 december into january okay
2019 and then from there on so may 2019
i attended the crash course with my wife
um
kind of knew i was going to join the
academy um
but i wanted to see it and i kind of
yeah just took uh took a plunger and you
used the money
to join the academy your property
yes and yes and you said as well that
you'd already budgeted when you
refinanced your house you thought i want
to go into property you're watching my
youtube videos
and you already budgeted some money for
training
yes why did you feel it was so important
to put some money aside for training and
not just put it all into property
because to be honest i didn't know what
to do yeah i didn't know what i wanted
to invest
but i didn't know how to invest in
property i kind of
knew that you could add value but i
didn't know all the different strategies
and i kind of didn't know uh the
compliance
and legality and all of that so you know
i didn't have the knowledge
yeah and from my background um in my
in my work it's always you train you
educate
then you move forward yeah rather than
just dive in
so yeah i mean on youtube
i mean i looked at a few other kind of
trainers as such and all i had from them
was it was a call
that just pay me some money and i'll
send you some videos and such
which really i was like that's not what
i'm looking for um
and then when we went to the crash
course
yeah i mean kind of that was it for me i
was in um
that was in july it was the same time i
give up
work but at the same time my son as well
he finished she finished school so we're
kind of on a journey together and we
have been
ever since um
and yeah so we done the launch pad went
straight in the rent-a-rent
revolution from that but from sort of
july
to september yeah i was on gardening
leave
and i'm thankful for my current employer
for that because
i use that time to get compliant for
deal sourcing
um again uh network like crazy
locally found a few mentors
on the way back from a crash course i
made a call to someone who i thought
i kind of knew they were in property and
i knew they were successful they were
local
and i kind of said can we get together
for a coffee uh
and he said yeah sure no problem so when
i went back we had a coffee
we met up and i kind of told him my
budget told him what i was looking for i
was looking for
properties where i can add value
and kind of left it at that really and
were you looking for properties to
package and sell
initially to package and sell yeah right
because you went from quick cash flow
yes yeah initially the package and sell
and i did i co-sourced
a deal with another academy member um
but then i quickly found out and
realized through bridging
if there's enough kind of uh
enough issues you can add value yeah
and therefore you know you get it you
get up to enough value you can pull like
all your money or leave a little bit in
the deal i remember selling you as well
on the net pull out all your money
course which is which is part of the
academy
yes and and um you told me that you were
like
if this works i can get out the rat race
yeah i'll be forever in your debt
i'll be coming down i'll be doing a
winner's wednesday video
and here you are so
it's on that rent to rent um the friday
before
i left it was i think it was a friday's
accidentally that
the gentleman who i approached after the
um
crash course rang me and said james i
think i've got a deal for you
it's um it doesn't fit his strategy so
it's very tired it needs work it's
commercial and residential
um the only issue is the landlord's in
spain
who is this guy that passed you this
deal uh it's a friend paul
okay paul he's he's not he's just a
local investor yeah sure
he's he's very successful in what he
does um
you know and again i'll be forever
indebted to him yeah
sure to give me the deal so i said to
paul i said look
well i'll go and see the landlord i'll
book a flight to spain
so we did the rent to rent friday
saturday and then the sunday i flew to
spain
now the reason for for going out the
reason why you couldn't come back over
is because he was a carer for a friend
um
but with the distance between himself
and the property
there was issues with tenants um it was
i mean he was kind of in the middle of
renovating it but the utilities
were a mess so you went to spain just to
negotiate with him yes
and and i mean many people would have
done a zoom call
well i wanted to speak to him face to
face yeah i didn't i didn't know him
uh i wanted to talk to him i wanted to
kind of
um be genuine i was in i was in the
position too because i just finished
work
um and yeah and i thought by
negotiating face-to-face we could we
could come to a deal and i come away
with an off i made an offer while i was
out there
that was accepted did you get a good did
you get the deal you wanted
yeah because i know the area i know the
area i knew i knew the potential value
i'll just say though jamie that what you
just did right there is the kind of
thing that
separates the successful people and the
unsuccessful people
like many people would say oh you know
he's in spain
can't really get hold of him but you
were like he's in spain i need to see
him face to face and i'm going to jump
on a flight
yeah because stoppable people would be
stopped by that yeah
but you're clearly an unstoppable person
well i i kind of sat when i came back
from that
trip i said someone said to my wife this
is it
this is our deal no matter what and
initially though when you went out i
think it was actually was it not poor
you
put all your money out the the brr yes
yeah so it was um
your pull on your money brr um
and yeah obviously i was kind of like it
was all sinking in i was like yes this
deal is perfect because
i've obviously view kind of i know the
area i know how much
uh the peak value is and i know that the
bottom value and i knew
you meet him you knew the deal yes you
got you fly to spain you meet him
yes and how did the conversation go well
it just so happened because he was from
the same area we knew
similar people there's a bit of an age
difference um
but kind of he had a problem he had a
problem selling it
there was a few things that needed
fixing um and he had a real bad issue
with tenants
um to the point where about two three
months stay in the line after we
had control of it as such and we
renovated there was still people trying
to access with different keys
there was a cannabis factory in the
attic um
yeah it was it was a you know it was a
mess
i think he was he was achieving 105
pound a week rent
at that time for the whole house for the
whole it was for the whole block
and it was commercial mixed with
residential 100
a week and that that's it yeah okay so
how much did you negotiate to buy this
mixed commercial and residential
building for
so the agreed price was 275 275kg
yeah um i obviously it needed works
but yeah i kind of knew there was a lot
of
room to add value okay now what i want
to know is exactly what you did with it
because that deal now is obviously
that's that deal has single-handedly
made you financially independent
you've got all the deals going on you've
got all the renovations going on
but talk me through the figures um
and also at what point did you decide or
realize
that you could finance it yourself
because initially you were thinking i'm
gonna package it and sell it
yeah that happened yeah so i was kind of
in the in the packaging
kind of flow and i went to see a local
specialist broker
howard bose and he kind of said to me he
said jame this is this is good
this is this is a good deal you may want
to consider
financing this yourself it's like well
i'm in you know packaging
so i said yeah okay and we sat down we
went through it um we done the numbers
and yeah
it was it was well within well within
reach to do
um i had a lot of help from my friends
and family
um to the point where uh all the
all the materials for the renovation
were on an account with a friend
so i didn't pay for that into the end to
the refinance
um yeah i mean i just had lots of help
because
i kind of people knew i was 100 in it
yeah i wasn't
kind of just dipping my toe in the water
i was going for it yeah
um so yeah from that point on we took
control probably around december time
when you say took control as in i i mean
part of the negotiation was with the old
landlord that
i helped him with the tenants right uh
just to square things up because
it was it was a mess uh the whole
property was kind of being abused
did you buy it on an option it was kind
of a delay completion
okay um so so yeah i mean
we kind of started renovating december
time i've got some pictures on my
facebook page of the boys
you know christmas eve we're in their
paint in a shop
we kind of navigate as well um
brexit yeah because we wanted the
valuation and the election mind
we wanted the valuer to value the
property after
these results had come through because
we didn't want any air of uncertainty so
i from i mean the conversations i've had
um is that if a value goes to a property
and there's uncertainty then they'll
kind of
yeah keep a bit back sure so we kind of
timed it so the valuer went there at the
right time
and that kind of got us into the bridge
side of it so you bought it for 275
yes how much money did you personally
put down into the deal
so all in all we were 85 in 85
000 in and we pulled out 70 000. hold on
so you bought it for 275 you put 85 of
your own money in the rescue bridge is
that correct
yeah so it was 275 was the purchase yep
the bridge
uh i think they give us about 230 to of
that purchase price the rest
i filled right so 275 garrison we then
renovated
with the bridge though i rolled the
interest up so
i was actually uh stuck in the bridge
during the pandemic which was
kind of a bit scary yeah because
obviously
interest on bridges is quite high but
they're very um
it's a very useful tool to get you what
you want
so how much was the refurb 27.
27 grand yes that is cheap yes very
cheap
so you bought it for 275 spent 27 on it
what did the
valuation come at that's what i want to
know uh four to five
incredible incredible so you made a you
made a lot of profit on that
yeah the the numbers were done
originally on
um 75 loan to value
of three seven five
so i think i mean we were pulling out
about two eight two
we ended up we got seventy percent of
four two five so we
uh we pulled eight two nine seven five
hundred right
um but yeah so we left 15k in the deal
um
it grosses 42k a year in rent
and the net is about 24. so that's
giving you a clean
profit of 24 000 pounds a year
yes and you only left him 15 grand
you made over a hundred thousand pounds
of equity
and literally that was your first
that was your first investment yeah that
was my first deal so because you've done
other deals but that was
packaging and selling code sourcing but
this was the first ever property
investment you bought for yourself
yeah and i mean there's a few advantages
as well that i didn't know about
in regards to um you know because it was
some it was a mixed commercial and
residential
it was a commercial a commercial
purchase all of it even though there was
four residential at the end
and we actually split the titles on
completion
right so we split the titles on
completion and another
we added gardens i mean if you have a
look on my face facebook page i've done
a
a case study on it we added
outside gardens so the three one bed
flats have all got their own private
gardens
during the pandemic obviously locked
down
it was kind of i i mean i i think i had
50 60 inquiries
per unit to rent out
but kind of having an outside space
during them times was was really good
how long did it take to get it all
rented out
instantly right so we we renovated
the two commercial units were done
within uh
48 hours and all the residential were
done within 24 hours
so that was a corker of a deal it was an
amazing deal
i know yeah yeah it was an amazing
congratulations by the way on that
massive well done thank you um and
i mean what would your someone that's
thinking i've got
85 grand i'm looking at i mean firstly
respect for just putting aside some
money for the academy
because a lot of people don't don't
you know they think and i'll say to them
like okay you've got 50 grand
put 15 aside for training and i think oh
you're only saying that because you've
got a training company yeah
well like i have i've spent more on
training
with kind of individuals
and and in groups yeah because
i you know i don't understand business
in a sense of when i went from my
my job to business i needed to run a
business
so opening limited companies cash flow
your taxes and that kind of i used a
three-month period
to kind of absorb all of that
information um
it's paid off though absolutely yeah and
people happily spend 40 grand
going to university yeah but but then
suddenly feel like oh my gosh 10 grand
for training
well kind of january 2019
um i had two diplomas to finish um
i've been kind of sat on them for like
18 months kind of
dipping in at night i kind of got into
the learning process off the back of
that
so i finished that and then went
straight into
to to kind of learn how the property
world works
and now you are full-time in property
right
yeah yeah i am so a typical day look
like for you now
so at the moment i'm based in in newport
as such so i spend a lot of time
within a local broker specialist
mortgage broker javi boze
um because i wanted to be in and around
property
constantly so there's lots of deals
coming in and and you know i get to pick
up things
so that's kind of a few hours there i'll
attend as many events as i can still
on network like crazy um zoom calls
uh i would say i go to the gym
from time to time but [ __ ] up at the
time yeah
and then i also support my wife with her
business so her business is
kind of a year down the line yeah
yeah i mean it's just it got to a point
i suppose
during last year that i actually
micromanaged myself
and plan my days in 30 minute segments
because there was so much to do
yeah so i mean i got a lot of stuff done
and i still kind of do that now it's
kind of calm down
um even with other renovations going on
what what um i mean when we met at the
crash course
uh 18 months ago or however long ago it
was may last year yeah
your son was at school wasn't he yeah
yeah he was just about to finish school
just about to finish school um and kind
of
i think we've all all had it we've read
rich dad poor dad you kind of get that
eureka moment where you think i've been
doing this wrong
yeah so i said to said to my son look
you don't have to go and get a job you
don't have to go to uni you don't have
to go to college
you can come along this journey with me
we can learn together
you'll obviously get financial reward
for it which he is
he's part of part of the limited company
um and yeah he said yeah okay i mean i'm
not worried about his ethics he's a good
boy he's switched on
but i want him to i want him to have the
freedom to follow his dreams
yeah so yeah here we are and i'll do the
same
with my with my other son as well you
have the same opportunity how old is
your other son
he's 13 13. mad opportunity though
and giving them giving them that
platform to learn
and that opening that door i mean you're
not giving any money to them like
obviously they're like
they're earning their money yeah
absolutely but the opportunity that
you're giving them
i mean is absolutely immense what's the
strongest reason that you're doing all
this like what's the thing that makes
you get up in the morning
legacy for my children yeah to build
to build a future for myself and my
current family um
like within my within my circle but then
also further out
um my mother-in-law she's retired
and she kind of needs some help now so
we're kind of back and forth here daily
this has allowed me to do that um and
yeah just
uh just to allow my children and their
children
to do what they want to do rather than
go into the
into the rat race as such and and also
like
you're working on other deals right now
so yeah talk to me a bit about those
so i mean i kind of the strategy to find
a deal i got no issues in finding deals
because i just look for problems
yeah and the bigger the problem the the
more negotiating you can do but also the
more value you can add
so we're currently in a in the middle of
a renovation just outside
internationally just outside swansea um
was a cannabis factory um
two flats yeah i mean we're just
straight into it
have you bought that already we're in
the process yet everything's with the
solicitors
um we've kind of how much you buying it
for 50
50 grand and what's the what's the
expected
costs in gdv uh the gdv is i mean
the estate agents have given me a
valuation anything from
145 to 185 so 145 160 180 and 185
yeah it'll achieve 160
all day long um the renovation is going
to come in probably about 40.
okay so you should be able to pull all
your money out yes
yeah we should be explain in your own
words because you've done all the trying
then you're on the academy you've done
the buy refurbished refinance master
class pull your money out
what does that even mean for anyone
that's just thinking i can't get my head
around this
how does that philosophy work so um
i'll give you an example one of the
first deals i packaged up
was um it was in bloon avon
in south wales it was purchased for 50.
the n value was 90 to 95
and the refurb was about 15. with your
soft costs
so yeah your legals and fees so 50
purchase 15 renovation you'd say a two
and a half k fee to 67 and a half
thousand
if you achieve a valuation of 90 to 95
when you refinance at 75 loan the value
you're probably going to pull all your
money out depending on what your end
value is so
you you're working up so 0.75
times the end value gives you the money
you can just get a new mortgage
yep absolutely yeah and i bet your
investor was happy
yes yeah um you still keep in touch with
them
um we have we haven't done any more
deals um
i mean as far as i'm aware everything
was okay uh
i set everything up i met him and his
company
yeah i mean my services were were
offered all the way through
so how many deals have you co-deal
sourced only one
okay um packages and sold any others
uh no just the one sure and then just
don't forget this i'm doing it myself
yeah yeah so just one deal packaged
uh and then i went into this one how
much did you sell that deal for
that code how much does it sell for
three three grand yep so and listen
packaging a deal and passing on for
three grand is okay
yeah i mean um
i remember it was the last viewing of
the day i'd viewed about
about 10 10 properties that was the last
one and there was a for sale sign that
dropped down on the floor
i kind of said why is that there or the
the estate agent said somebody's just
pulled out it was sold but it's not so
yeah i mean it was kind of lucky i
suppose that i was there at that time
but but you put yourself there i put
myself there and that's the thing as
well people call
say it's lucky and it might be but when
you keep putting yourself
in the right place at the right time
with the right knowledge
you're just gonna get lucky absolutely
he's like tiger woods he says the more
practice the luckier i get
yeah i mean don't get me wrong i was the
fact that
i was handed a deal as such or
you know i guess i am lucky um but
hundreds and hundreds of hours of effort
have gone into it yeah and you joined
the academy
yeah and you put and you opened yourself
up and said i'm looking for deals
you put yourself out there you start
doing videos on facebook yeah
um i mean the whole journey has been
kind of a roller coaster really because
you get your highs you come off the back
of an event and you and you're flying
and then you're like
nothing's happening and then you go back
again um and then of course when you're
in the middle of a deal you've got all
these issues that are being popped up
you know solicitors um you know planning
permission
kind of all these things you kind of
ride in the wave but ultimately
consistent action over a long period of
time
yeah you're going to get there that's
what i teach i always say i actually
say when people say i'm on my property
journey i also actually it's a process
this is a this is
a it is a journey but it's it's also a
process and if you follow the steps a b
c you will get there yeah absolutely
yeah
i mean i'm not um i'm not expecting it
to to be a millionaire within a you know
a few years i'm just on a steady steady
road
building each time slowly probably gonna
do another four
get another four units uh before i move
on now to
potentially a hmo which i'm going to use
um
you know use the funds all the way
through continuing to invest
i mean i'm looking after my own
properties at the moment through another
management company
um i mean i suppose the challenge will
be for me is when i start investing
outside of my
kind of patch but again i think i'm
lucky in where i am situated so south
wales at the moment
i see a lot of academy members doing
well um there's a lot of people
investing in south wales you know as far
down as swansea
so i think i'm in a right area yeah i
think so i'm
you're in a great area yeah i'm happy
like capital appreciation is good
yeah you can guess you can achieve some
really good rents and you can still pick
up pacers for 50k
yeah so yeah you know there's lots
there's lots of opportunity
talk to me about the experience of the
training because
i know it's our training is high energy
yeah
it is what's been like so so when we
first
attended the crash course me and my wife
we i mean we were
kind of skeptical and after because we'd
been on a few training courses together
before and
after like a couple of hours you're like
but then all of a sudden you know we're
bouncing
it's like really high energy and i'm
like
okay let's give it a go let's go with it
um
and after after the crash course we kind
of said yep i said yep i'm in
i'm done and then after each i mean i've
still got some court some
some courses left to do because of the
you know the delay
but yeah i mean all throughout i mean
the guys
uh in and around support you so i kind
of
used alastair's book yeah as a template
to set up
the deal sourcing because i needed
clients yeah i needed i just needed a
tick box
kind of that's that's what you do okay
great um
so yeah i mean i'm looking forward to
the live events i really am
um but yeah just really just only just
that in my journey
we've only just recently started doing
the live events again yeah so we've been
doing everything virtually on the
academy
um i know who's who's been who's been
your your met your mentor
business mentor yeah sue collins sue
collins
cool and that's part of the academy yes
yes so we have a
i'd say monthly uh business call with
sue
in my group we've got a mastermind group
of five of us
um i spoke to moe yesterday he give me a
tingle because he's set up and running
now so
so yeah the support within the groups is
great um
i mean you don't have to know everything
you just need to know someone who
correct
who knows it you know i always say that
show me your friends
and i'll show you your future right and
who you surround yourself with is
is who you'll become and i think it's
really important
to be around other people that are doing
property that are doing
um are doing well i mean how important
do you think it is to have people around
you that are winning
absolutely because i mean something you
said is just look for someone who's
just in front of you yeah so that's
exactly what i did i
went back home i looked at a local
investor
um i kind of started networking and then
my day-to-day role was just property
property property whether that's
reviewing properties
um you know meeting people meeting other
sources
meeting other property investors people
who are just
you know a few years down the line yeah
and kind of
you don't have to reinvent the wheel you
just have to they'll do exactly what
they do they'll celebrate more though if
you're if
if you get your first deal and
you're around family members who've
never done a deal they'll be like oh
that's a bit school i'm not sure
whereas if you do your first deal and
you're around people who've got three or
four deals they're good for you
yeah it's the same as if you become a
millionaire and your friends are all
worth 10 million
they'll be like yes about time if you
become a millionaire
and your friends are all worth 100 grand
yeah who do you think you are so
i'm always trying to get around people
that are doing better than i am
yeah bit of inspiration it's a bit of
inspiration and also
you know their their learnings can be
passed direct to you then yeah you know
avoid that don't do this and like you
said i mean
i remember when i announced to my to my
family group that yeah
i packed in work i'm not saying that's
right for everyone but it was right for
me at the time i
i'd had some friends in the background
i've prepared for it
um and yeah because i've always had like
a good job as such
so the kind of the career path i was on
to say no
i'm going this way it was a bit of a
shock to everyone but i had nothing but
support
nothing but support from from family and
friends that's really good and you're
the kind of person that
that really honest people which i think
is great i do i mean
whoever you know whoever's helped me
along the journey i'll be forever
grateful for because
well you've driven all the way from
wales today yeah just just to share and
say thank you and you know i appreciate
i know you said you would you
told me you would and i appreciate you
doing that yeah um so what's next then
you've got a few deals in the pipeline
like what's what are you most excited
about right now
um bigger the better yeah i i
i'm going to look for more commercial to
residential yeah
so i believe there's going to be a lot
of commercial property coming up soon
um whether that's locally or or you know
along the m4 corridor
so yeah i mean i'm not i'm not phased by
the numbers as such
you put an equal amount of effort in if
the deal stacks yeah the deal will stack
um so yeah i mean there's a there's a
few
benefits of commercial purchases so 150
i think it's 150k
you don't pay any stamp duty so on that
d on the channel it's massive savings
checks on the the chapter deal in
newport uh sorry the chapter road deal
in newport i've paid 2200 stamp duty
yeah or land tax you know so
there's some great benefits there's some
great opportunities uh and i know
there's a lot of doom and gloom at the
moment but there's some fantastic
opportunities coming up within the
property world whenever i just doom and
gloom though
james cons has observed the masses and
do the opposite and whenever everybody's
all worried and scared and that's when
you should really be getting in
yeah i mean but also there's a lot of
people that want to get out at the
moment so
like you say there's landlords who want
to get out yeah um
for whatever reason and i'm kind of
coming into the game
so yeah what would you um what would you
say to somebody
that was wanting to get started but just
didn't know where to look for didn't
know how to find deals
what's the first steps so i mean
just just have a look online so look on
youtube like yourself you give a lot of
content
for free um but you know be careful
because you don't just go diving in
make sure that you you understand your
strategy so whether
it's brr or you know rent to rent
whatever you want to do whatever
if it's cash flow is it long term
but just educate yourself yeah as much
as you can
steadily just just i agree
you want to get excited you want to go
yeah and you you get all excited about
you know yeah i want to get my first
deal so just for me
um managing my own properties and
refinancing
because i was deemed as a kind of a
non-experienced
landlord the rates were a bit higher so
if i was
kind of i would never say no to the deal
again but if
if i was to do it again i potentially
would get some kind of landlord
experience
underneath my belt with a small yeah
single biter yeah so then you can get
bigger and bigger and bigger i think
that's smart i think um
i i when you say bigger is better i
totally agree with you because it takes
just as much effort on a big deal as it
does a small deal absolutely at the same
time when you're just starting out
you're probably going to mess up on your
first deal
so you should probably make mistakes
yeah start a bit smaller and also start
with education i think what you did so
well and the reason you're sat on that
chair
is because you said i've just refinanced
my house but i'm going to put some
of it towards training and educate
myself because this is a business at the
end of the day
absolutely and like i said too early i
i've spent more than what i spent on the
academy
um you know and i don't regret spending
anything you've got private mentors
you've got
local people that you've paid and that's
good yeah absolutely i'm i think i'm
impressed
and nice you know how much i spend on
training yeah yeah
you know continually talk to me about
your son like what does just what do you
think your son thinks of you
and working with you
well kind of he's he's got
a lot of freedom at the moment yeah um
but for me i just want him to have the
time
to follow his dreams so to get him into
good habits so he goes to the gym every
day
he does a bit of revision every day he
helps out with both businesses
every day i haven't thrown him in at the
deep end
i just think that i check in with him
every now and then you sure
are you okay you can go and get a job i
can i could get him a job
tomorrow you know paying three four five
and a pound a week
but that's not what i want for him and
as long as he's
on board with that and he understands so
you kind of you ask the questions as
we're going through the deals and he's
like what does hey does that work out
and then
we kind of we go through it together
yeah
so yeah i mean and he gets a lot of for
me it's freedom for him for time
i think you know when i look back i
think wow
if he if he's 17 now if he has 20 years
in property from now where could he be
yeah and same for my other son uh archie
he's gonna have the same opportunity um
and i just wanna
i want both of them to be successful but
both of them to do
and follow a passion it's great and i
love your passion for your kids and also
passion for business and property
what was your previous job what were you
doing i was a leader in logistics so
um from 18 went straight into a
warehouse
work hard um you know i never had a day
off
worked up the chain up the ladder then
kind of
yeah i mean i've always had a good job
i've always been well paid
i did enjoy it i enjoyed the challenges
why did you want to get out the rat race
so bad
what were you like samuel get me out of
this rat race
because i was living in someone else's
dream it was a friday afternoon
um and i was looking out the window it
was the sun was blazing and i'm
i'm somewhere where really i didn't want
to be in a sense of
there was other things so i wanted to i
didn't want to miss
any of my sunspot both of them i wanted
to be free to watch both of them
enjoy their sports and yeah i just
thought there's got to be more
there has to be more my aspirations i
mean
i was setting goals for myself but i was
on a i was on a kind of a train that was
never going to get me to that
destination
yeah i was always going to fall short so
i was kind of in a good place where my
family were at
so we like my wife was super supportive
financially it was okay it was it was a
calculated risk there was a certain
amount of time
uh probably had about 12 months to to
get everything going and start getting
some some income
but yeah i mean it was it's just to see
just to see
you know what i can achieve and what we
can achieve as a unit as well
so my family have been integral to
to the support they've given me like you
know my mother
and father that my mother especially
she's kind of like
you giving up your job yeah but now
she's seeing it she's seeing
and now the questions are coming so hey
yeah and how did you all right okay yeah
so i think we're a future investor
along the line so so yeah i mean that's
that's
i wanted to support my mother-in-law my
mother-in-law's not like i said not very
well
um she kind of needs our assistance
so between me and my son that's what we
do daily
it's just the freedom just the freedom
to to enjoy life
yeah that's so good and i mean we've
been working together now for the last
year or so yeah
what's what would you recommend the
training like what's it what's it been
like would you if someone that was
thinking going to the crash course
they're a bit skeptical what would you
go i would just say go to the crash
course go to the crash course um
you know experience it
yeah it may be for you it may not be for
you but i would say definitely go
the amount of content you give for free
first of all do
do the youtube then go to the crash
course then make a decision from then
and then choose your strategy go for it
yeah um
you know whether whether you're in a
similar situation to me where if
i was you know where i am in my life
where i could afford to take a risk
or if you want to plan for it i mean
just experience it
yeah experience it and then go for it
but then if you go for it go for it
yeah 100 well massive congratulations
thank you mate i really
respect what you've done respect you're
coming out from all the way from wales
to shane's story
thank you and looking forward to seeing
you a future upcoming event
or a dinner or wherever we'll see today
yeah thank you
thanks so much
[Music]
the